i read something about you where your
kids were like
dad why can't you do a show more like
ellen degeneres where we could just like
hang out with cool celebrities and stuff
that's right yeah why do you guys
they were also like eight at the time
now now my daughter like i'll come
downstairs and my daughter will be
watching john oliver and i'll be like
what are you doing there she's like it's
just a really interesting treatise on
how
uh
you know
repossession industry is corrupt within
that and i'm like holy [ __ ] oliver is
raising my children this is awesome yeah
did you find yourself getting um envious
of those guys when you would watch john
oliver or you know
no i don't know my brother no you
weren't no you weren't like oh [ __ ] i
want to get back into the mix i want to
no no no no no no no those guys are
doing you know
i i love what they do so it doesn't you
know and i love those guys like that's
the other thing that that you remember
is like oliver stephen you know
we had so much fun working together and
i don't i don't have like regret or envy
or any of those things because
i'm astonished at how well shit's worked
out for me
so and i never had that sense of that
someone else's success was to the
detriment of mine i i always
i think it's it leads to such bitterness
when you when you look at
the world as finite
and you resource guard it
it leads to such
bitterness and
it's destructive as an emotion and i've
always felt that
you should
everybody's success expands
for you or for anybody